Transcription: Danielle Bellet-Edimo
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonjour.
Avez-vous confiance en vous ?
Moi, je suis justement
en train de la travailler,
et j'avance bien.
Et oui, la confiance ça se travaille,
ça se construit petit à petit,
et tout au long de votre vie.
Aujourd'hui, chers étudiants,
vous êtes à un moment de votre vie
où il y a peut-être pleins d’opportunités,
ou plein de réflexions,
plein de certitudes, ou plein de doutes.
Certaines choses vous semblent possibles,
et d'autres beaucoup moins.
Et vous verrez, dix ans plus tard,
ça sera toujours le cas.
Alors en travaillant votre confiance,
elle va vous permettre
d'aller plus loin plus sereinement,
pour atteindre vos rêves
ou changer de voie,
et en tout cas, pour faire
ce pour quoi vous êtes faits.
Pour vous donner un exemple,
aujourd'hui j'ai un master en marketing,
et je travaille dans un
environnement multiculturel.
Je parle donc anglais toute la journée.
Eh bien, je peux vous dire qu'au début
ce n’était vraiment pas gagné.
Moi, j'aurais dû redoubler mon CP
selon la maîtresse de l’école.
Je n'aurais jamais dû faire l'IUT
d'Annecy beaucoup trop sélectif
selon la prof principale de terminale.
Alors faire une licence en anglais, vous
voulez vraiment que je vous en parle ?
Oui mais voilà, je voulais
faire l'IUT d'Annecy,
alors j'ai envoyé ma candidature,
et j'ai fait un sorte de les
convaincre durant l'entretien.
Quant à l'anglais, il y a
toujours des solutions.
Je reconnais que les concours d'entrée
pour aller dans des pays anglophones,
vu mon niveau d'anglais,
ça allait être compliqué.
Mais j'ai trouvé la solution.
La Norvège était le seul pays
où il n'y avait pas de concours d'entrée.
Oui, il y a dix ans en arrière
la Norvège, ça semblait loin et froid.
Personne ne voulait y aller.
Donc, bien sûr au début j'ai galéré
avec mon niveau d'anglais.
Mais au but d'un ou deux mois,
ça allait déjà beaucoup mieux.
Et entre nous, toutes les occasions
sont bonnes pour pratiquer la langue :
les soirées étudiantes, ça aide bien.
Ce que je veux vous dire, c'est
que ça se fait et que ça se travaille.
Quand on n'a pas voulu
me faire passer par la porte,
eh bien, je suis rentrée par la fenêtre.
Et ma première ressource
pour y arriver, ça a été mon instinct.
J'ai toujours eu la volonté
profonde de l'écouter.
Parfois, ce n'était qu'un murmure,
mais il me disait tout le temps :
« Fais ce que tu aimes. »
Et même quand ce n'était qu'un murmure,
ça m'a donné l'impulsion
pour construire mes projets.
Alors, voilà les trois choses qui me sont
personnellement essentielles
pour accroître ma confiance en moi :
du positif, du courage,
et de l'inspiration.
Et voilà quelques astuces
pour les développer.
Le positif, oui, ça se travaille.
J'utilise une méthode très simple
mais terriblement efficace
qui est de noter tous les soirs trois
choses que j'ai aimées dans ma journée.
Et même quand j'ai passé
une très mauvaise journée,
ça peut être l'odeur du café
le matin qui m'a plu,
ou une chanson à la radio
qui m'a donné envie de danser,
ou j'ai tout simplement adoré
aller me coucher
parce que cette journée
est enfin terminée.
Pourquoi ça marche ?
Parce que des études montrent
que 90 % de nos pensées
sont les mêmes chaque jour.
Et que la plupart d'entre elles
sont négatives.
Ce qui veut dire que neuf sur dix de
nos pensées, en plus d'être récurrentes,
pour la plupart sont négatives.
En identifiant simplement
trois choses positives par jour,
on finit par changer
de perspective sur sa propre vie.
Plus on crée de l'espace pour le positif
et plus on apprend à savourer
les petites choses,
à s'en souvenir, et à les ancrer en nous.
Des études montrent qu'au bout
d'une semaine de pratique seulement,
il y a déjà des effets notables sur le
bonheur et qu'il s'amplifie avec le temps.
Ça vaut le coup d'essayer, non ?
Je vous conseille de vous engager
à le faire avec quelqu'un.
Ça aide à le faire quotidiennement.
Deux : le courage,
même combat, ça se pratique.
Et pour moi une des méthodes qui marchent
le mieux, est de faire une fois par jour
quelque chose que je n'ai
encore jamais fait.
Et là encore ça peut être
des toutes petites choses
comme par exemple, changer
d'itinéraire quand je vais au travail,
ou faire mes courses
dans un supermarché différent,
ou tout simplement essayer
une nouvelle recette de cocktail.
Peu importe, ce qui est important,
c'est de le faire régulièrement.
Et là encore, pourquoi ça marche ?
Parce qu'en tant qu'être humain,
on a la capacité d'accepter de très grands
changements et d'être flexible.
Cependant, c'est souvent notre peur
qui parle en premier.
Ce sentiment de peur, il est désagréable,
mais il ne dure pas longtemps.
Car même si la nouveauté nous effraie,
elle emmène aussi en nous
une sensation de curiosité et d'intrigue.
Cet exercice nous fait sortir
de notre zone de confort
et prendre confiance en nous.
Il transforme nos peurs en impulsion.
Utiliser nos peurs comme moteur,
cela nous permettra de mieux
affronter les futurs obstacles.
Trois : l'inspiration.
Si j'avais écouté toutes
les personnes qui me limitaient,
aujourd'hui, je ne serais pas là.
Mais on a aussi tous autour de nous
quelqu'un qui nous inspire.
Et j'ai eu, durant mon parcours
universitaire, particulièrement à l'IAE,
des profs super inspirants
qui m'ont poussée, motivée
et donné envie d'avancer.
Alors entourez-vous de
ces personnes qui vous inspirent.
Laissez-les vous embarquer
et écoutez leurs conseils
ils sont précieux,
parce que l'inspiration, c'est
l'étincelle qui va vous permettre
de construire votre projet,
votre rêve, ou votre idée.
Il n'y aura peut-être pas 15 000
personnes qui vous inspirent,
mais des fois, il suffit d'une personne
ou même d'une phrase,
pour nous donner l'impulsion
dont on a besoin.
Alors, pour augmenter sa confiance en soi,
il faut du positif, du courage,
et de l'inspiration.
Certains d'entre vous ont peut-être essayé
d'atteindre leurs projets, leurs rêves.
Peut-être que ça n'a pas marché
et que vous n'avez plus confiance.
Eh bien, persévérez
aussi longtemps qu'il le faudra.
Est-ce que vous savez combien
de fois tombe un enfant
avant d'apprendre à marcher ?
Environ 2 400 fois.
Et est-ce que vous savez pourquoi,
après toutes ces chutes,
il finit quand même
par apprendre à marcher ?
Parce que ses parents n'ont aucun
doute sur sa capacité à marcher.
Alors sur ce point, soyez
votre propre parent.
Ayez confiance en vous
et dépassez vos limites !
Je ne vous dis pas que c'est facile ;
je vous dis que ça vaut le coup,
car la vraie question au fond,
ce n'est pas ce que vous pouvez faire,
mais ce que vous voulez faire.
Et c'est à cette question que
j'aimerais que vous réfléchissiez.
Que voulez-vous vraiment ?
Qu'est-ce qui vous anime ?
Quand on fait taire toutes vos peurs,
toutes vos voix limitantes,
qu'est-ce qui reste ?
Alors maintenant,
chers étudiants, c'est à vous !
Quel est votre rêve,
et quel est le prochain pas, aussi petit
soit-il, qui vous rapprochera de lui ?
Merci de votre écoute.
(Applaudissements)